- Swearing gets a bad rap.
For a long time, it was associtated.
(BEEP) Let me try again.
Swearing gets a bad rap.
For a long time, it was associate.
(BEEP) Swearing gets a bad rap.
For a long time, it was associ.
(BEEP) Mind is a
piece of (BEEP) today.
For a long time, it was
associated only with poor
or low-class people.
In fact, the word vulgar
originally just meant common.
But if you've ever watched "Succession,"
you know that today the rich and powerful
drop plenty of F-bombs.
- I'm not dignifying that (BEEP)
question with an answer.
You can both (BEEP) off.
- Despite their popularity,
the gatekeepers of language
often like to pretend that
bad words don't exist.
Dictionaries and etymologies ignored them
for hundreds of years, which is why today
it's so hard to tell how they originated.
Anything that even
sounds like a swear word
gets scrubbed from acceptable vocabulary,
which is why donkey and rooster
have replaced their forerunners.
Even Shakespeare had his cusses
removed from some editions.
- Zounds, What a tragedy!
- But so-called bad words
are a fundamental part
of human vocabulary and
there is some evidence
that using them in moderation may actually
be good for your psyche.
I'm Dr. Erica Brozovsky and
this is Outerwords. Otherwords.
(BEEP) We'll do it live.
(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Otherwords.
- Even the cleanest mouths
among us have stepped on a Lego
or gotten some bad news
and let an expletive slip.
Linguists call this
non-propositional swearing,
meaning unplanned, almost
involuntary outbursts.
For a long time, psychologists
discouraged this type
of swearing because it
thought it catastrophized
negative emotions, meaning
it made you feel even worse.
But then why would we all have
this reflexive urge to do it?
Ow, son of a (BEEP).
This is what psychologist Dr.
Richard Stephens wondered.
And he sought to test it
with a very cool experiment.
Participants were asked to
hold their hands in buckets
of ice water for as long as they could,
once while repeating a swear word
and once with a neutral word.
No matter what order they went in,
swearing increased the
average amount of time
they could withstand the pain by 50%.
The swearing was acting as some kind
of pain management mechanism.
Subsequent studies bore
these findings out.
And there was evidence
that swearing was effective
at lessening social and
emotional pain as well.
In some experiments, it
seemed that the naughtier
the word was, the more effective it was.
So saying shoot or gosh
darn was like taking
children's Tylenol, better than nothing
but not as good as the real deal.
Like medicinal painkillers,
they can also be overused.
People who tended to swear a lot got less
of a benefit from it.
To understand what the F is going on here,
we'll have to take a look
inside the human brain.
Most people know that the brain is divided
into two hemispheres, the
left side which specializes
in higher order reasoning
and the right side
which is all about emotion and creativity.
In reality, it's quite a bit
more complicated than that
but you get the idea.
Most of our language functions reside
in the left hemisphere, which
makes sense because a language
involves the arrangement
of complex thoughts.
Swearing however seems to rely more
on the right side of the brain.
This has been witnessed by
neuroscientists in real life.
People who suffer massive
damage to the left side
of the brain often lose
significant language ability,
a condition known as aphasia.
However, many of them retain
their ability to swear
and tend to swear more often.
Conversely, many who have
suffered damage to the right side
of the brain can still
speak clearly and coherently
but seem to lose the
ability or urge to swear.
Swearing, at least the
non-propositional kind,
is clearly more of an emotional reflex
than a rational behavior.
That's why some linguists
think it's more akin
to a dog's bark or a lion's growl
than human language.
It quickens the heartbeat, dulls pain,
gets us ready for action.
And because it's so
associated with emotion,
swearing can actually help build trust.
Studies show that groups
that swear conversationally
tend to forge stronger
bonds and perform better
at shared tasks.
Displays of emotion like swearing
are generally interpreted
to be more genuine and harder
to fake than ordinary speech.
And breaking taboos in front
of other people implies a level
of shared trust and understanding.
Swearing can even minimize
the potential for violence
by offering an outlet for aggression.
Instead of throwing
punches or pulling hair,
we can show how (BEEP) we
are with words instead.
Such displays of aggression
as a substitute for violence
are pretty common
throughout the animal world.
The words we consider bad give us power
because they are taboo.
But if you go back 500 years,
it was the other way around.
Bad words were considered taboo
because people believed they had power.
Back then naughty language was
focused on God and religion.
Invoking the deity's name,
swearing by something sacred,
or cursing someone were
supposed to have real effects
in the real world.
This is why we call them swears, oaths,
and curses or cusses.
Some of Shakespeare's favorites,
'sblood, 'slid, zounds,
were shortening of God's
blood, God's eyelid,
and God's wounds.
If you're swearing by God's body parts,
the next thing you say better be true
or your soul may pay for it.
And you didn't say "damn you" or "go to hell"
unless you really wanted someone
to go to hell, like literally.
As culture became more secular,
taboos shifted from religion
to things like sex,
excrement, and body parts,
though it's hardly universal.
In Germany, some of the
worst swears involve animals,
calling people dogs or pigs.
And in Japan, there's not
such a stigma around feces.
In fact, they seem to
find it kind of cute.
So having a (BEEP)
might be a good thing.
Whatever the taboo is, the important thing
is that it's shared.
We've all collectively
agreed to put certain words
behind glass, not so
that they're never used
but so that we can know when
(BEEP) gets real.
It may not be the most
sophisticated form of expression
but there's a primal magic to swearing
that's still with us
after thousands of years.
And like any magic, if
you use it too much,
it can lose its powder.
Power! (BEEP)
Wait, before you go.
I think you're gonna love "Fate & Fabled",
a brand-new show here on Storied.
Co-hosts Dr. Emily Zarka
and Dr. Moiya McTier
unpack ancient myths
and legends to find out
why such tales were
crafted and investigate
mythology's influence on humanity.
Their first episode on the
Fates is live right now.
So maybe it's destiny that
I'm telling you about it now.
Be sure to tell them Dr. B sent you.
But then why would we all have
this reflexive urge to do it?
Ow, son of a pinch.
So having a jiggy day might
be a good thing. Fungi.
Otherwords. Fudge it, we'll do it live.
But so that we can know
when chin gets real.
Power! Butterfrogger!